what do you think about elon musk going
to colonize mars
is this something you find an
interesting or
a
aimless pursuit i think it's a must or a
salvation we need to leave at some point
the planet because historically in the
past we know that we've been bombarded
by a steroid volcano
they're crazy things happen here it's
very unstable you know we
if you look at it to
through a lifetime of a human being it's
nothing but just look 12 000 years ago
what happened you know so there is
cataclysm that happen all the time it's
very unstable so
if we want to survive as a species i
think it's it's we need to get out to be
able to get out and
spread our seeds so these are the early
steps on uh on a really long journey but
is there something about like
you know we we don't get that
exploration from most of modern society
you know the kind of exploring that
people did throughout the centuries of
uh you know coming to the
north america just throughout we were
shrouded in physical uncertainty of
what's out there
and now we get to do the same kind of
exploration with mars
is there so i mean is there any aspect
of you that wants to travel out to space
that wants to travel to mars
there
you know the goal is to allow civilians
to travel
perhaps in our lifetime
meaning affordably you can do so now
unaffordably
traveling to space and traveling to mars
or
two different things i think i would
like to travel into space
i don't know if i would like to travel
all the way to mars because of the risks
involved
just because
boring
is there some part of you that enjoys i
think that if i was like towards the end
of my life i would like to travel
tomorrow because it's just just the
experience yeah but if i go to mars i'm
not coming back i think that's it
one-way ticket
with the technology we have now maybe in
the future maybe our
the children of our children will will
be able to to experience that to go to
well the the weekend on mars
uh well the the whole design of the
starship that the spacex is working on
is supposed to come back
it's supposed to be reusable so it's not
it's not a one-way ticket that's the
whole point
it's always going back and forth back
and forth what's the time frame between
two planets
like to travel from i think the current
thing you'd be stuck on mars for two
years
but how long does it take to get from
earth to mars oh it's pretty i'm not
exactly sure but it's pretty quick
that's pretty quick like i don't know on
the scale of months not scale of years
you might not be healthy when you come
back you know all the astronauts they
experience health issues you know they
lose a lot of muscle mass bone density
so yeah i don't think the technology is
good right now i mean
let's say that if it is i would love to
be doing it for a weekend if it's safe i
would like to be there first one two to
eight or a professional fighter who
sacrificed his body for something so
there's some sacrifice we do in life
right i don't want to be there first i
wouldn't want to i leave the other one
but when i know it's it's safe
okay count me in so one of the things
that people say and this is something i
wonder about is
it's like having children or something
once you see once you're out in space
and you look out and you see earth you
look back at earth that's an experience
that's unlike anything else like you
can't replicate it here
um is to look back at that like blue dot
and that's nerve-wracking
you see like earth disappear into the
distance
yeah yeah disappear
into the distance and then you get this
actually stand on mars and see
and just to look you're standing on the
ground and you're looking out and you
see the planet from when she came and
where you might not be coming back but
there's a challenge to the whole thing
whereas the risk is tremendous
and
i don't know i find that risk really
compelling for some reason but that
could be just the exploration
i guess that's a genetic thing too how
much do you want to explore
there's a sense though in which even in
the best case scenario where they did
get the technology to whisk you to mars
in a in a fairly short period of time
it's kind of an inauthentic sense of
exploration because
your participation in it is
no more exciting than
your participation in an airline flight
to a foreign country you're basically
you you didn't have anything to do with
the creation of the of the vessel you're
not in command of the vessel you're not
in any way shape or form important to
the mission you're just a person sitting
in a passenger seat and you get off in a
destination the same way you would if
you flew to singapore or london or
someplace like that well there's a
hierarchy
of there's a leadership and then there's
a bunch of people and they all have
roles you don't get to go to mars
without having a skill set but you you
made it sound like space tourism where
you just yeah
i i don't i think it's a long time
before you have space tourism to mars
where you have nothing to contribute
okay like you will have to what do you
do you go through like a training
program you go training program and then
there's uh there's technical things
you'll be contributing so they would
bring
people
you know in terms of agriculture i don't
know okay so this is this is better this
sounds like they're actual they're more
like explorers like if you talked before
about explorers in in human history
where magellan sets off on his boat and
every person on the boat had a specific
function they were they were all
into the mission in a very authentic
fashion if they weren't on the boat the
performance of the crew would somehow
suffer so this sounds much better and
with just what like with magellan i
think most of the crew died
a significant number did yeah